in Washington today the Trump
administration plans to brief
congressional leaders on the military
operation that killed general Soleimani
defense secretary Mark Esper and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo will
defend President Trump's decision to
target Iran's most influential military
leader in response to an attack that
killed a u.s. contractor in Iraq the
president insists Americans are now
safer while Democrats demand proof that
the attack was necessary Ben Tracy is at
the white house Ben what are things
stand now well president Trump has
promised to answer any retaliation from
Iran with even more force meanwhile the
Democrats want to know what exactly was
the imminent threat that led President
Trump to order this strike on the
Iranian general and what is his plan to
avoid in all-out war the American people
need clarity that the Trump
administration has a plan
president Trump did not notify Congress
of his decision to kill sulemani until
the day after the strike Democrats are
now planning to force a vote on a new
War Powers Resolution to restrain
president Trump's ability to launch
further military action against Iran
unless Congress approves Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says Democrats are more interested in
blaming President Trump than focusing on
national security
can we not maintain a shred just a shred
of national unity for five minutes but
Republican Senator Rand Paul said the
killing of suleimani is the death of
diplomacy with Iran you would have to be
brain dead to believe that we tear up
the agreement we put an embargo on you
and we kill your major general and
they're just gonna crawl back to the
table President Trump defended himself
on Monday saying the United States is a
lot safer now we'll see what happens
we'll see what their responsive is if
any but you've seen what I said our
response will be the president is
threatening to strike fifty two sites in
Iran including cultural ones which would
violate international law but three
senior administration officials either
publicly contradicted mr. Trump or said
that he had not said what he said adding
to the confusion Monday the Pentagon
circulated a letter announcing
a withdrawal of US forces from Iraq but
the Pentagon later said there is no
decision to leave Iraq and it was just a
draft it was a mistake an honest mistake
Democrats called the disorganization a
danger to national security it says that
there's mass chaos that the Trump
administration hasn't a clue about what
it is doing now that draft letter
announcing a u.s. withdrawal from Iraq
comes after the Iraqi parliament voted
to kick US troops out of that country
the Pentagon now claims it simply wanted
to warn the Iraqis of u.s. troop
movements in the area Anthony then thank
you
you